sie sind die elegantesten vögel im
europäischen luftraum die kraniche auf
dem darf an der deutschen ostseeküste
kommen sie zweimal im jahr zu besuch um
sich kraft anzufuttern im herbst für den
zug nach süden im frühjahr um zu ihren
brutgebieten zu fliegen biodiversitäts
experten marion stricker von der
umweltbehörde unep möchte sich das
naturschauspiel genauer anschauen an
ihrer seite jörg schmiedel der als
kranich experte für den bio andy an der
ostseeküste arbeitet
[Applaus]
es kommen jetzt laufend wieder bis in
die späte dämmerung und dann sind wieder
komplett rasten alle im schutz der insel
ich sehe es kommt auch noch so ein
schiffchen vorbei viele leute kommen
auch vorbei um die kraniche zu sehen
speziell hier oder da ja das ist der
renner alle fahrgastschiffes betriebe
der region die sind ausgebucht und
kranich was zeit ist das denn nicht
störend für die kraniche also das ist
doch eigentlich naturschutzgebiet dürfen
die schiffe da überhaupt richtig fahren
wir hier vorne ist fahren so richtig
aber es ist auch schon wichtig dass der
nationalpark seiner nationalparks acht
hin und wieder mal präsenz zeigt das
heißt nicht dass die leute gleich
verhaftet werden aber schon sehr
deutlich darauf hingewiesen werden dass
sie hier unter anderem auch die
wirtschaftliche existenzgrundlage der
region zu stören würden in einer chronik
saison kann man bis zu 90.000 graue
kranich er auf der halbinsel darß
beobachten und das hat einen historisch
interessanten grund die region liegt
unterhalb der seegrenze der ehemaligen
ddr deshalb waren große gebiete der
mecklenburgischen boddenlandschaft
sperrgebiet das wieder wirtschaftlich
entwickelt noch stark besiedelt war es
gab also platz und ruhe für die kraniche
während des kalten krieges war die
gesamte küste mit wachtürmen gesäumt die
die flucht von ddr-bürgern in den westen
verhindern sollten nur die tiere
kümmerten die grenze nicht nach der
wende wurden zum glück für die kraniche
große teile der grenze in ein
naturschutzgebiet verwandelt das
sogenannte grüne band jetzt mehr als 30
jahre nach der wiedervereinigung gibt es
nur noch eine handvoll krenz türme wie
hier in klausdorf wo er eine
touristenattraktion geworden ist mit
besten blick auf die küste
[Musik]
ja genau wir sind ja noch nördlichsten
festland kannte mecklenburg vorpommern
findet dort befindet sich das grüne band
dahinter kommt gleich die so bock die
insel hiddensee und dann diese üben
weiter nötig geht es nicht um festland
die vorpommersche boddenlandschaft ist
ein nationalpark mit strengen regeln für
die besucher damit die strände
naturbelassen bleiben das war nicht
immer so am ersten oktober 1990 zwei
tage vor der wiedervereinigung wurde der
nationalpark als eine der letzten
amtshandlungen der ddr eingerichtet
sollte damals setzt sich annett sturm
für den umweltschutz am boden ein doch
was genau ist eigentlich dein job oder
was macht also ich bin die vorsitzende
vom förderverein des nationalparks von
landschaft und wir haben dann wirklich
auch gleich als die wende kam oder sich
das alles abzeichnet haben wir gesagt
wir wollen irgendwas hier für den
naturschutz tun und haben mit freunden
diesem verein gegründet und haben uns
dafür eingesetzt es gab schon auch runde
tische also ist dass der nationalpark
gegründet wurde ist eine bewegung aus
dem volk heraus sind inzwischen gibt es
eigentlich kaum jemanden doch der den
nationalpark in frage stellt im
gegenteil die größten kritiker sind
heute befürworter weil sie merken dass
es auch für sie einen vorteil hat
hier an der küste findet man immer noch
bernstein das von den kiefern
stieleichen und rotbuchen des
staatswaldes stammt im nationalpark wird
der wald urwüchsig ohne eingriffe durch
den menschen belassen und durch das
feuchte klima und den schutz hat sich
hier eine besondere artenvielfalt
angesiedelt dieser feuchtgebiete werden
immer seltener in mitteleuropa sind aber
lebenswichtig für den kranich wenn sie
im frühjahr aus dem süden in die
boddenlandschaft zurückkehren finden sie
hier schutz und nahrung nach der langen
reise und manche kranich pärchen bringen
hier sogar ihren nachwuchs auf die welt
kraniche gelten als eine der tierarten
die die menschen auch emotional
erreichen und dadurch für den
naturschutz werben kann hier brauchen
eigentlich das ganze jahr feuchtgebiete
während der rast jetzt brauchen sie die
feuchtgebiete als schlafzimmer also die
stehen im flachen wasser um dort schutz
vor creation zu haben noch wichtiger
sind die feuchtgebiete während der
reproduktion das heißt kraniche bauen
ihre nester auf dem boden und um schutz
vor prädatoren beispielsweise in
deutschland vor füchsen zu haben muss
das von wasser umgeben sein und insofern
ist der kann ich derjenige mit dem man
sehr gut
mit schutz betreiben kann der ist
einfach sichtbar
der kranich schutz deutschland begleitet
und beobachtet die vögel ganz genau
jungtiere werden teilweise beringt und
mit gps sendern versehen damit man mehr
über die flugrouten und das verhalten
der grauen kraniche erfährt am münster
sehen zusätzlich mais und weizen für die
tiere ausgelegt und damit auch der
besucherstrom gelenkt so können
internationale vogelbeobachter die
kraniche tanzen sehen ohne sie zu stören
auch marion strücker trifft günter
nowald sie an einem der größten kranichs
plätze der welt die ehemalige grenze der
ddr hat an der ostsee einen image wandel
vollzogen hier schafft man es
naturschutz tourismus und
wirtschaftliche interessen miteinander
zu verbinden und gleichzeitig den
lebensraum des kranichs zu erhalten